- I'm so happy to be here.
- I am so happy you're here as well.
And also your colors are,
this is, you're like a,
you like, glow as you walk
in. This is beautiful.
- I have to tell you this,
and I think some people
may or may not know this,
but when you come on your show,
I try to make it a look that
I think you would appreciate.
- Okay.
- Reflects the experience
I'm gonna have here.
- [Kelly] That is very kind.
That is very kind.
Yeah, if you dress poorly,
I'm gonna be like, "Get out!"
- [Mindy] Get out of here.
(laughter)
- But anyway, are you
excited, like with your kids
for like the holidays coming up?
My kids love decorating
and doing all the stuff.
- Oh my gosh,
they're crazy about it.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- My daughter, well,
she's born December 15th.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So it's just
a month-long party.
- I always feel sorry
for December birthdays.
- Yeah. As of now,
- [Kelly] Jesus totally
trumps you every time.
(laughter)
It's like, it's like, sucks.
- Well she just thinks of it
as like starting December 1st is just
like preparation for
Christmas and her birthday.
It's just party month. So right now,
she just like, loves it.
- [Kelly] That's pretty good.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] An optimist. I like it.
Well, you've got something
else to look forward to.
So I hear that next
year is "Walk Of Fame".
You're getting your "Walk
Of Fame", your star?
- Yes.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] That's so crazy.
- Thank you.
- That's so cool.
- You've had yours.
- I literally just had-
I just did mine, and I-
And you know what, I'm gonna tell you
the weirdest thing about it.
It's awesome. All of it is awesome.
But I have never, in 20 years
had everyone from every part
of my career under one umbrella,
like one tent for one thing.
It's the first time that's ever happened.
So you're gonna look out
and see people that range-
- [Mindy] That sounds very stressful.
- [Kelly] You know what? It wasn't.
- It wasn't
- [Kelly] No. I tend to not
keep those people around.
- [Mindy] That's smart. That's smart.
- Yeah.
- [Mindy] I just, and
like, so I, first of all,
I don't know who to invite.
I'm like, am I gonna
fill the number of seats?
'Cause I'm like kind of a homebody.
Second of all, like, there's
so much, there's like,
do you put your hands in
the, is that just in the-
- That's, that's Grauman's,
That's Graumans, where they do the,
That's a different thing.
It's right there, like
where the stars are.
But it's, it's a, I learned this.
- Wait, there's two different ways
- [Kelly] Exactly!
- That we commemorate famous people.
- [Kelly] I did, Exactly.
We come up with them.
I didn't know this either, and
so whenever it was happening,
I was like do I have to
do my hands or something?
They were like no, it's Grauman's,
so it's like-
- Wait, I'm here
getting like all like excited
to do that photo where I-
- Well, you do the photo
where you're on the ground with the star.
- [Mindy] Yeah.
- Which try and
look attractive in that environment.
(Mindy laughs)
Like I, I literally saw the pictures
and I was like, I guess approve.
Like, they're horrible.
But like
- [Mindy] Yeah but like,
- It's just like the most awkward
- Like you have to lay down
sideways on the dirty street.
- Yeah. It's not great.
That look isn't great, but
I'm sure you'll pull it off.
Yeah. I didn't and I
just leaned into humor.
But, but will your
Office costars be there?
Will people that you've been
working with, you're gonna
invite them right?
- I'll invite them.
Yeah, I'll invite them.
They're pretty busy. I
think there's a couple
that'll definitely definitely come.
- Yeah.
- But I think it'll be fun.
I'm one of these people I
don't like to ever, I mean
I try to, but I have trouble
reflecting on success,
cause I'm superstitious and I
feel like, oh, you spend too
much time thinking about
like, oh you did a great job
or you should commemorate this
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That something bad is gonna happen.
It's like, I don't know.
I'm just like one of those people.
So sometimes big life, like milestones,
like I didn't do a baby shower,
I didn't do any of that stuff
cause I was like
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't wanna jinx something,
I've just always been this way.
- [Kelly] Oh, I'm so opposite of you.
- And so this, this, well listen,
that's the healthy way to be.
- Yeah, I didn't actually
want a baby shower
because I hated pregnancy
and I just wanted all
humans to get away from me.
(Mindy laughs)
But like, but most time I think it's,
I think, try and think of it though.
It's also kind of cool to go.
I, I think because in my career,
I don't know if you feel the same,
you forget things that happen.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Like you forget
because you didn't take the
time to have that moment.
You didn't take the time to have that,
- [Mindy] To commemorate it.
- Commemorate it, yeah.
- [Mindy] It's really true.
- Yeah, so I don't know.
What the hell do I know.
- [Mindy] Like to my kids. No to my kids.
I can be like, see I'm like a big deal.
Don't give me any crap.
- [Kelly] No. I'm telling
you my six and eight year old
were there and they were like,
they literally leaned over
to my mom and my sister.
I can't remember which one it was.
And they were like
why is everybody like
yelling like for my mom?
Like she, they were like, they
just thought it was so weird.
- [Mindy] Yeah.
- So it's kind of, it's kind of cool
to see you're like, yeah,
this is, Mommy works hard.
- [Mindy] Yeah.
- It was like, it's kinda
nice to be like, that's right.
- Yeah no, it's true.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] It's, It's nice.
But anyway, you posted
this photo recently,
so I wanna show this.
Like this is throwback.
- [Mindy] Yeah. It is
- [Kelly] Like is this when y'all
first kind of started the show?
- Yeah. So when we first did The Office,
I mean this is so sweet.
The first two seasons of The
Office, whenever it aired.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We would go over to someone's house
and we'd like watch the show together.
Which is something
- That's so cool. People don't do.
- No people don't do that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And I thought that was normal.
But like Steve was like
the star of the show
and like you could tell by the snacks,
like this is not a fancy party.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- And Angela,
- These are my people
with that snack tray.
I'm like, cool.
- Yeah. Like, just like
pretzel sticks and everything.
And Angela, we just took turns throwing it
and there wasn't this idea of like
oh my house isn't fancy enough.
Cause it was Hollywood.
Like we felt so separate.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Well the show is not that glamorous
or anything when you watch it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
But I just, when I saw it, I
first of all was like, wow,
that's so fun that we do that.
And second of all I was
like, Steve Carell is so hot.
(everyone laughs)
I feel like he doesn't get enough credit
for being like kind of a babe.
- I'm gonna own this right now.
So I have always thought he was cute.
Right. But he came here
and it was for our first,
it was for the first
- [Audience Member] Premiere.
- Premiere. Yeah. Because he
did the Kelly Clarkson thing.
- Of course in 40-year old Virgin.
- This dude hanging out
backstage, he had like a,
like a long, like trench coat like thing.
He had all this salt
and pepper facial hair.
I was like, oh okay.
(audience laughs)
I was like, what the hell
is happening right now?
- [Mindy] Yeah.
- Literally the buzz
the entire day was
how hot is Steve Carell?
- [Mindy] Steve Carell.
Yeah.
- I was like,
(audience applauds)
I was like, what?
Anyway, so I'm with you on that.
I love though that that
was your first experience,
you were saying like in a big way like
of experiencing Hollywood.
- Yeah.
- Cause I think we all are this,
you know and then you know,
your career happens
- [Mindy] Yeah.
and you get to like maybe
elevate your snacks.
- Elevate your snacks. Exactly.
- But sometimes you don't
want to and you just
wanna go back to the pretzel
sticks cause it's easier.
- Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- You're from Boston, but
now it looks pretty evident
that you are an LA Lakers fan.
I'm just gonna show these photos.
You are really into the game.
You like going to games.
- [Mindy] Yeah, I love going to the games
and you know, for my dad, you
know, we grew up in Boston.
He loved basketball.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Mindy] He's a big sports fan.
And to be able to take
him to the game, like,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's such a big deal.
I'm doing a show right
now about the Lakers,
about Jeanie Buss who owns the Lakers,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She's an incredible woman.
- Oh, We've had her on here.
- [Mindy] Yeah. She's incredible.
So it's, so this is research,
I guess you say is like
going to these games
and it's, it's amazing.
And I was just there and
LeBron is there obviously.
And it's such a great opportunity
to just take these like
creepy photos of him.
(laughter)
You know, it's like,
- Why can't they just be photos?
Why do they have to be creepy.
- Well cause he's like
doing something else
and sometimes he'll just be
like on the bench and I'm just
like taking pics of him
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because he's just so famous.
I mean, I mean
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Worldwide he is so famous,
but just like, it's LeBron.
Like he's just amazing.
So that's what I spend my time doing.
- I just pictured you at the game
the whole time taking shots.
- [Mindy] Yeah.
- Did you see the game? (laughs)
- You know, honestly like
I was, I had to like,
my dad was like, hey,
we're here to see the game.
- [Kelly] This is a game.
- Yeah.
- But it's like, it is, it is truly,
It is truly amazing.
And he's like, you know, so he's
like one of one of my most
favorite people alive.
- [Kelly] Yeah man. Great player.
- Yeah.
- I love going to games, like
for the mingling and the food.
- Yeah. Yes.
(laughter)
- And the game.
- [Mindy] You know what
my fear is about the food.
- [Kelly] In that order.
- Is like, I'm so worried
that when the camera,
if you have good seats,
if the camera catches you
and you're just like eating a hamburger,
and then you, the player
falls on you or something.
I just like, I just wanna seem dainty.
So I just like sip water whenever.
- I think just early on, like, yeah, no,
I've had like the worst
photos of me taken like,
in a bathing suit, like going
down on like a big hot dog.
Like I've had the worst photos,
like, like a wave coming up.
And I'm not like Heidi Klum.
It's just like, and it's like, you know
it's so comedic that I just
lean in and don't care.
- I feel like most of my life
is avoiding becoming a meme.
- I am 100. I don't care.
(Both laugh)
- Like, meme it up.
I'm like, I don't care.
I'm gonna live my life.
I'm gonna have the hot dog.
(laughter)
Did LeBron ever notice
you taking pictures?
Cause you're really recognizable?
- No. So one time I went to a game and he,
I was sitting with next to
two people I didn't know,
and he came down and he waved,
and I assumed like clearly
that he's waving at somebody else.
Like why would he be waving at me?
And then I looked at
the two guys to see like
who LeBron's friends
were and they were like,
we don't know him.
And I was like, I think
LeBron was waving at me.
Maybe he's a big, The Mindy Project fan.
We never knew.
- Wait.
- [Mindy] Yeah. So he
gave me a little wave
- And you didn't wave back?
- No, because I didn't know it was me.
So now he probably thinks I'm unfriendly.
- He thinks you're a snob
- Because I big timed him.
So now he'll know, cause
- [Kelly] Yeah.
We're gonna get this message out.
- I just, you know.
- She would've waved
LeBron. She would've waved.
- [Mindy] I would've waved back.
I didn't wanna be, you
know, the worst feeling
is when someone waves
and you're like, hey.
And they're like, we don't care about you.
It was the person next to you.
I didn't wanna be that guy.
- Yeah. I've been that person a lot too.
Yeah. I feel like I'm a lot
of what you don't wanna be.
- (laughs) No, no. This is like.
- You know you should hang out with me.
You'd feel really good about yourself.
- [Mindy] No, this is like.
- I will cover the ground
of all the other things
and I won't care.
How, how do you think though,
like speaking of that,
like in the public eye
thinks happening or whatever,
how do you think that's
affected you being a mom?
Because I feel like it, it
changed my perspective on things.
- [Mindy] Yeah.
- I was already kind of nonchalant about
a lot of industry things,
but I think it just kind of
changed my perspective even in
my relationships with people.
Did that, did that change for you?
- Yeah. You know, I think
it's, the thing with my kids is
that I'm really private
about them, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I, it's hard because I
love them so much and I talk
about them so much, but I
don't put them on social media.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I don't judge people who do
because like every time
they do anything cute
I wanna put them on there.
But I'm also like, they're not
really consenting to it, so.
[Kelly] Yeah.
- But in terms of just
like the projects I do,
I do wanna do shows about young women
who are not perfect,
but who like learn to
accept themselves, you know,
and who don't look like the kind of women
we've seen on TV before.
You know, it's, and it doesn't seem
like that profound or
anything, but it just,
I didn't have that growing
up and it would be nice
if it was on TV for my daughter.
- [Kelly] For our kids, yeah.
- And again, I'm forgetting
about my son who also needs good TV.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But he, he'll be fine.
- [Kelly] He's fine.
(audience laughs)
- He'll be fine.
- No, I will say, so Sex
Lives of College Girls
on HBO and your Netflix
show, Never Have I Ever
are both young women kind of
finding themselves, right?
- Yeah.
- So this is a thing
that is super important to you.
- Yeah.
- Cause it's
a narrative you like.
- Yeah. I mean I think the
thing is, is I wanna make shows
like first and foremost
that like make you laugh and entertain.
I feel like life is hard.
- [Kelly] Well done. Accomplished.
- Thank you.
I wanna go home and just turn on the TV
and be like entertained.
I don't always need to
see serial murderers
and like all that kind of stuff.
And I just feel like I wanna
make something that's funny.
If they can be funny and
they look a little different
than what people are used
to, like even better.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't wanna like preach
at people and you know
try to make, you know,
teach people lessons
and make them feel bad about themselves.
I just want them to see
different perspectives.
So that's what I'm trying to do.